[Music]
Hello and welcome to I'd like to know
our Bible question and answer program
here at SumTV. My name is CA Murray and
I'm sharing the desk with our founder
and president, Pastor Steven Bore.
Pastor, always good to search the Bible
with you.
>> It's good to work with you, too. I
learned very much. And we praise the
Lord for that. We also learn a lot from
you as you send in your questions which
give us an opportunity to study the word
of God. Something we love to do and to
answer your questions so that we know
where you spiritually itch if I can dare
say that. And um we have a lot of fun
doing it. We want to give you the
contact information right away. If you
want to get in on the fund, send a
question, uh do so at tvsumtv.org.
That's tvsums suum m as in marytv.org
and we promise we will get to your
questions and we will answer those
questions from the word of God. If an
answer can be found we will find it and
if not we'll tell you that too. But uh
so far God has been pretty good to us
pastor and we've been able to answer
most of the questions that have come in.
>> Yep.
>> We've had one or two technical things
which are sort of medical questions
which a little above our pay grade but
anything biblical we've had a good time
with and we have to answer. Amen. Now,
before we go on and have prayer, um
you've got a couple good-looking books
there that are a project of all your
diligent labor. Just tell us what you
have there as far as study notes are
concerned.
>> Well, the study notes I'm going to
recommend is because later on we're
going to have a couple of questions.
Yes.
>> That deal with some of the issues that
we have in the study notes.
>> The first one is Behold, I send you
Elijah. This is a very important uh
booklet that I prepared.
>> Good stuff. uh it was presented at a
summit and uh basically the question
always comes up is Satan going to
personate Christ before or the after the
close of probation
>> and uh this um material actually answers
that question fully and completely
>> and in depth
>> and when we come to the question I'll
share some of the details
>> um the first question that we're going
to deal with uh actually is dealt with
in another study note which is
misinterpreting the texts on the state
of the dead.
>> Misinterpreting texts on the state of
the dead.
>> Uh basically I take all of those
difficult passages uh on the state of
the dead like uh
>> absent from the body and present with
the Lord. Preaching to the spirits in
prison. Um fear him who is able to kill
the body but not the soul. All those
difficult texts I deal with fully and
completely in these study notes. And uh
we have some questions that we're going
to deal with later on that this would be
very helpful if people get a copy of the
study notes on the state of the dead and
behold I send you Elijah
>> and you as you can see these are very
thick so they're kind of exhaustive uh
pretty much cover the subject from stem
to stern from top to bottom from alpha
to omega from dan to bretha uh are
covered in these study notes so this is
something you can get and uh which will
help you uh as you study the word of god
for yourself.
>> They're exhaustive, not exhausting.
>> Praise the Lord. Praise the Lord. All
right, let's have a quick word of
prayer. Now, I want to go into our first
question, which comes from Gracious from
the country of Malawi. Gracious father,
we thank you and praise you for this
opportunity. Bless us just now. We want
to do your will. We want Christ to be
glorified. And we thank you in Jesus
name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> All right. Gracious writes from Malawi.
According to the King James Virgin
version, we are dealing with John 10 17
and 18. Here are the questions that
appertain to that particular text uh
portion of scripture. Um,
therefore doth my son love me because I
lay down my life that I might that I
might take it again. That's verse 17 and
18. No man taketh it from me, but I lay
it down for myself. I have power to lay
it down, and I have power to take it
again. This commandment I have received
of my father. Um
uh and then King James uh 2017, she's
going to chapter 20:17. Now Jesus said
to her, "Touch me not, for I am not yet
ascended to my father, but go to my
brethren and say unto them, I ascend to
my father and your father and to my God
and your God." Here's the question. Does
the soul of Jesus go up to the father?
Help me understand what the testimonies
uh with the testimonies of Ellen White
and Bible quotes. One of the things
that's very very important in your
understanding of the state state of the
dead is that the soul doesn't go
anywhere. Uh at the point of death, the
soul ceases to exist. And that
understanding,
dare I say, blows away pastor a lot of
the fog surrounding the state of the
dead. And that's why your your your
study notes are so important.
>> Uh the soul can't go anywhere because
the soul is a composite entity. It's
body and breath. When body and breath
are separated, the breath goes back. The
body goes to the ground. there is no
soul. So to answer the question as as
stated does the soul of Jesus go up to
the father? The answer is no because uh
there is no soul to go up to to the
father.
>> Actually the person who submitted this
question is really answering u his or
her own question.
>> Yes.
>> Because basically there are two texts
that appear to be contradictory.
Uh the first text is John 10:17 and 18
where it says, "I lay down my life and I
take it up again."
>> So uh he's speaking about his
resurrection, right?
>> Yes.
>> But then in the other text, John 20:17,
Jesus says, "I have not yet ascended to
my father."
So he didn't his soul didn't go to
heaven when he died.
>> Right? Well said.
>> Because the third day saying, "I haven't
ascended to my father yet." So, so one
text actually answers the other text.
>> Very well said. Uh,
but something did happen uh that we were
talking about just a little bit ago that
um again helps us in our understanding
and um why at one point he says touch me
not and then later on he says touch me.
Do you want to read that writing from
early writings page 187? Uh I let me see
if I can find it here. Uh okay. Early
writings page 187 and 188 uh the context
is the feast of first fruits.
>> Yes.
>> Which pointed forward to the
resurrection of Christ.
>> Right. Right.
>> Uh so um on resurrection morning Jesus
made a quick quick trip to heaven
>> and presented himself before his father.
Uh and the reason for that we know
because in Matthew chapter 28 uh when
he's about to ascend to heaven she he
says to his disciples all power or
authority is a better translation. All
authority has been given has been given.
It's a perfect tense.
>> Yes.
>> Has been given to me in heaven and in
earth.
>> Well
>> when did he get that authority?
>> When he ascended on resurrection
morning. Here's a statement. Early
writings 187 188. Jesus spoke to her
with his own heavenly voice, saying,
>> "This is when he meets Mary."
>> Yes,
>> Mary.
>> She was acquainted with the tones of
that dear voice
>> and quickly answered, "Master."
>> And in her joy was about to embrace him.
But Jesus said, "Touch me not, for I am
not yet ascended to my father. But go to
my brethren and say unto them, I ascend
unto my father and to your father and to
my God and your God. Now, here comes the
key portion. Joyfully she hastened to
tell the disciples with the good news.
Jesus quickly ascended to his father to
hear from his lips that he accepted the
sacrifice and to receive all power in
heaven and on earth.
>> Amen. Pastor, would you do me the favor
of reading that last line once again?
Jesus.
>> Okay. Jesus quickly ascended to his
father to hear from his lips that he had
accepted the sacrifice and to receive
all power in heaven and on earth. And
then Matthew 28:9, Jesus says right
before he ascends to heaven, all power
actually a better translation is
authority. I don't know why the versions
translate power. Power is dunamis.
>> It's not exucia.
>> All power has been given to me. It is a
passive aist. In other words, an action
that began in the past and
>> and continues in the present.
>> So all power has been given to me in
heaven and on earth.
>> Just before Jesus ascended to heaven, he
said these words. Therefore, he had
received authority from his father
before this. Mhm. Mhm.
>> Well said. I think that's a that puts a
nice little bow on it. He got Christ's
burden
>> once he came from the tomb was to to
understand that his sacrifice was
accepted.
>> Mhm.
>> And so he made the trip to get that
understanding cleared and he did do so.
he came back and then uh we we have that
uh imperfect tense thing there. And
>> and somebody might wonder and say,
"Well, Pastor Bo, how do you know that
Jesus fulfilled the feast of the first
fruits?" Because what happened is um
when when the harvest was just about to
be ripe, um a priest would get a sheath
of uh grain
>> grain
>> and he would take it into the presence
of God in the holy place
>> and he would wave the sheath.
>> How do we know that that points forward
to Christ? That Christ presented himself
before his father as the first fruits.
The answer is in 1 Corinthians chapter
15 where the Apostle Paul very clearly
says that Christ has risen, our first
fruits.
>> Yes. Right there.
>> And so very clearly
>> Jesus presented himself before his
father in harmony with the feast of the
first fruits.
>> Amen. And amen. It's it's a beautiful
thing. It's a comforting thing. Um
Christ had the power to lay his life
down and and take it up as he well said,
but he waited for the call of his
father.
>> Yes.
>> You know, everything was done in concert
with his father.
>> Right.
>> Um and so when when the angel said came
down, that was the call. Up he came. So
everything was done in concert with his
father. And the first thing he wanted to
know once he resurrected was that my
sacrifice has been accepted by my
father.
>> Right?
>> And all power was given to him. And then
later on when Jesus ascended
he presented himself before his father
again
>> according to revelation chapter 5 and at
this time you know Jesus personally
received the approval of his father when
he ascended on resurrection morning.
>> Yes. But then when he ascends with all
the holy angels and all heaven is
waiting to meet him
>> now the father proclaims to everyone
that his sacrifice has been accepted.
>> Amen and amen. Amen. A beautiful study a
beautiful understanding of the word of
God and what God has done for us through
his son Jesus Christ. And thank you
gracious for your question. Uh and thank
you from uh contacting us from Malawi.
All right. Um,
this is Donna
>> from New Jersey.
>> From New Jersey. The question is, was
Jesus peaceable or impeccable?
>> Okay. Um, obviously he was peaceable.
>> Amen. And amen.
>> Because the Bible calls him the prince
of peace.
>> Prince of peace.
Not only that, but Jesus said, "My peace
I give to you," he said to his
disciples.
>> Yes.
>> When he calmed the storm, he said,
"Peace be still."
>> So clearly, uh, Jesus is peaceable.
>> He is peace. In other words,
>> yes.
>> Now, is he impeccable?
Um, by the way, we have in Spanish the
word picado.
>> Mhm.
>> So, impeccable means they didn't sin.
>> Yes. Well, the Bible says that Jesus
didn't sin, too.
>> So, he's both peaceable and impeccable.
>> And impeccable.
>> Now, impeccable would mean that he was
not able to sin.
>> But, but we know that Jesus could have
sinned.
>> Yes.
>> But he never allowed his sinful human
nature to express itself in sinful acts
or sinful thoughts. Yes.
>> Etc. And so um the answer to this
question is very simple and that is that
Jesus was both peaceable and impeccable
in the sense that he never sinned. Maybe
we can read Hebrews 4
>> ah
>> on that particular point. Hebrews
chapter 4 14-16
>> and here we go. So, Hebrews 4
4:14-16.
All righty. Hebrews 4. And I'm picking
the reading up at 14.
Here we go.
>> That looks like a new Bible.
>> Uh, it's an an older one that I haven't
used for a while.
>> Verse 14. Seeing then that we have a
great high priest who has passed through
the heavens, Jesus the son of God, let
us hold fast our confession. For we do
not have a high priest who cannot
sympathize with our weaknesses, but was
in all points tempted as we are yet
without sin.
>> So very clearly
>> powerful.
>> He never sinned. Mhm.
>> Uh doesn't mean that he couldn't have
sinned by choice.
>> Yes.
>> But he chose never to sin.
>> Mhm. Jesus came with a a a a fully
functioning relationship with his father
which he kept throughout his life. You
mentioned sometimes you learn things
from me. One thing that I learned from
you, it just never occurred to me that
Christ even in his daily activities got
instruction from his father as to how to
do what to do that particular day and
how to follow through. So it was this
lockstep relationship, this fully
functioning relationship with his father
that he kept intact. And through that
relationship, he was able to resist sin.
>> Amen.
>> It's powerful. Amen.
>> So again, thank you, Donna. Uh from New
Jersey, it says Donna M. My sister's
Donna M, but she's not in New Jersey.
She's in New York.
>> Same thing. Just across the river.
>> Just across.
Praise the Lord. Now, this one is a bit
longer. Let me look at the clock on the
wall. We can get through this. This is
from anonymous. Uh it's addressed to
you, but of course we will try to look
at this together. Um Michael, uh it says
at the end, thank you for your ministry.
I know I speak for thousands of
believers globally who watch your
lectures and videos and are uh blessed
by the clarity that you bring to
scripture, especially lectures on Daniel
and Revelation and your your question
and answer platform. You know, we found
this out and I I'll take it just a
second. At the general conference, many
people came by uh our booth and said how
blessed they were by this particular
program.
>> Amen.
>> And us wrestling with the scriptures
>> uh on their behalf um and uh the
thorough way that that you who are our
leader and and our mentor and and uh
really an example to us dig into the
scriptures and it encourages us to do
the same. answer the question.
>> Uh my question not necessarily will not
may not necessarily be beneficial to the
public platform but I leave it that to
your discretion. Okay, here's a
question. I have friends who are part of
a charismatic movement. They believe
that we are living in end times. And
they believe that all true believers can
be prophets
uh and prophesy with with word given to
them by the Holy Spirit and through
dreams given to them uh by the Holy
Spirit. I have also noticed that many
so-called prophets uh on YouTube
including pastors of churches like uh N
mentions these other churches
uh to name a few all these people
validate that they are prophets in the
end times uh and the end time prophetic
word is true with scripture especially
Acts chapter 217 Joel 2:28 I do not
believe that these scriptures are for
our end time uh help your help in
understanding these verses will be
greatly appreciated um because we have
the Holy Spirit and the writings of in
the book of Ellen White. I do not
believe that
uh there is any need for future prophets
or prophetic word and there are not any
future need for apostles or disciples.
So he wants understanding as he wrestles
with with this this thing. Uh
particularly uh I have heard people use
Joel 2:28 um
young men doing dreams, older men have
visions as as word for a continuing
prophetic ministry uh into the end of
time, a prophet prophetic ministry of
all believers. And I think that's what
he's running into. Well, the bottom line
is that the New Testament makes it very
clear when the Apostle Paul gives uh the
list of uh spiritual gifts that that
Christ gave to the church
>> that uh there will be prophets in the
church until the coming of Christ.
>> Um but the but the definition of the
word prophet as a spiritual gift um has
a restricted sense and it also has a
broad sense.
When we look at the word prophet in the
New Testament, uh when it refers to the
gifts of the spirit, it's really
speaking about teaching concerning
prophecy.
>> Yes.
>> It's not a prophet in the technical
sense of the word like uh John the
Apostle who received the book of
Revelation or Daniel who received the
the revelations that we have in the book
of Daniel. Those are technically
prophets that are called as a vocation
for life.
>> Uhhuh. But there God will raise prophets
in c certain circumstances in the end
time to deal with certain issues or
problems in the church. Also,
individuals who teach Bible prophecy uh
in a certain sense are called prophets
in a general sense. It's not in a
restricted sense.
I don't believe that God is going to
raise up another prophet like Ellen
White who's going to spend an entire
lifetime
uh receiving visions and dreams and uh
writing books and giving personal
testimonies. But I do believe that the
book of Joel tells us that in the end
time, God is going to uh is going to
raise up prophets in certain
circumstances
uh to deal with certain issues in the
church. Um Ellen White uses Joel chapter
228-32
where she says that in the future there
will be individuals who have the
prophetic gift in a general sense of the
word. Um maybe we can read Joel chapter
2 uh in verses 28-32. It says, "And it
shall come to pass afterward that I will
pour out my spirit in all flesh." This
referring to the latter reign, by the
way, "Your sons and your daughters shall
prophesy. Your old men shall dream
dreams. Your young men shall see
visions. And also on my man's servants
and my maid servants. I will pour out my
spirit in those days. and I shall show
wonders in the heavens and in the earth,
blood and fire and pillars of smoke.
Then it says, "The sun shall be turned
into darkness and the moon into blood
before the coming of the great and
awesome day of the Lord." And then it
says, "Whoever calls on the name of the
Lord shall be saved." And then for in
Mount Zion and Jerusalem there shall be
deliverance as the Lord has said among
the remnant whom the Lord calls. Uh so
Ellen White applies this passage on
repeated occasions to uh individuals
that God will raise up at the end of
time to uh you know to help the church
uh in explaining prophecy as and also to
help the church work through difficult
problems at that particular time. Um so
but there's not going to be another
prophet uh I don't believe that God is
going to call as a prophetic vocation
>> where they're going to dedicate 70 years
like Ellen White. Yes. Uh to edifying
the church. Ellen White played the role
similar to Moses
>> with the 7th Adventist church to restore
everything that had been torn down
during the period of papal dominion.
>> Yes. Yes. Well said. And I I I went to
Acts chapter 2 and the words are almost
the same. I mean, it lays so clearly on
top of and it I won't read it at all,
but and it came to pass
>> and and it shall come to pass in the
last days, says God,
>> that I will pour out my spirit on all
flesh. Your sons and your daughters
shall prophesy. Uh doesn't say they'll
hold a prophetic office. they shall
prophesy which means they will give the
word in needed season for needed
occasions. Prophesy also means preaching
you know right uh doesn't always mean
future telling it means forthtelling as
far as future telling. So uh uh your
young men shall see visions, your old
men shall see dreams. Uh lays perfectly
on top of Joel 2:28. Um and I I think
your explanation is good. uh a prophet
per se. The Bible doesn't countenance,
but people having prophetic gifts for
prophetic for specific occasions. Yes, I
think this text and the text you just
represent
>> and by the way in the question uh it
says um let me see if I can find all of
these people he's giving names of
individuals who appear on television
>> uh these mega pastors. All these people
validate that they are prophets. Now um
validate means to confirm that they have
the true prophetic gift. But the Bible
makes it clear that there are tests of a
true prophet.
>> Yes.
>> By the fruits you shall know them
>> as one.
>> These mega pastors, I see them very
concerned about uh money
>> uh you know about uh prosperity, a
prosperity gospel
>> uh and many scandals among them. Um also
uh the bi the Bible says that uh we have
to test a prophet if they teach in
harmony with scripture.
>> Yes.
>> And many of these are teaching that
Sunday is the day of worship. That
disqualifies them.
>> Yes.
>> Uh by their fruits you shall know them.
>> Right.
>> Whether they teach according to the word
of God,
>> the law and the testimony, they speak
not according to this word.
>> No light.
>> If what they prophesy is fulfilled,
>> yes. Yes. Yeah,
>> many of these are teaching false
prophecy
>> and uh finally if they teach that Jesus
has come in the flesh.
>> Correct. Correct.
>> And so you apply those tests to see if
their claim is validated.
>> Yes. There are five specific tests to
anyone who professes to be a prophet of
God. They must match not four out of
five, five out of five. And many of
these so-called prophets fail in that uh
in that manner. Well, our time is fast
slipped into eternity. In closing, we
wish you grace and peace through our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. We'll see
you again next time. Bye-bye and God
bless.
[Music]